special thanks to opera gx for
sponsoring today's video hello my lovely
people and welcome to my review of the
soul society particularly its second
half last week i covered the beginning
and this week we discussed the climax as
well as all the narrative tricks kubo
implemented to pull this proverbial
rabbit out of this narrative hat this
arc was enormously fun to read and
review so without further ado i'm
totally not mark and these are my first
impressions of thoughts on and review
for an arc that honestly needs no
introduction it's the undeniably widely
beloved arc that tells the classic
hero's journey in a powerful fashion it
is of course bleach's soul society the
conclusion
[Applause]
so as many of you might have noticed in
the first part of my review for soul
society i outlined the introductory plot
points that built up to the significant
midpoint in the narrative ichigo chooses
to accept the call to action at the
beginning despite the dangers with him
meeting a series of increasingly more
difficult physical and introspective
challenges helping him to become a more
complete individual until he finally
makes it to the top of the proverbial
mountain or in this case literal tower
to achieve the goal he is set out to
accomplish to challenge the final boss
that stands in his way from rescuing
rukia who i am quite literally
struggling not to call damsel in
distress atop a tower i'm realizing
however just as ichigo steps forth to
challenge this proverbial dragon in
byakuya this is where kubo decides to
implement what most writers refer to as
a midpoint reversal i've mentioned in
this video's intro as well as in this
arc's first half that what helps the
soul society feel so much more cathartic
and complete when compared to something
like substitute shinigami which i did
also enjoy was its adherence to a more
traditional story structure and the
implementation of a midpoint reversal
further demonstrates this a midpoint
reversal is a particular technique an
arthur might use to increase the
intensity or drama of a particular
conflict in the case of bleach's soul
society it's ichiko's dramatic arrival
and intense confrontation with biakuya
this midpoint reversal however is
achieved by providing a surprising
turnaround to shake up either the status
quo our expectations and or the general
direction of the story and boy does that
happen in bleach but it can be seen in a
large variety of anime and western media
also pretty much every arc of one piece
has this midpoint reversal in alabasta
for instance we're introduced to the
characters and culture of the island we
arrive with a goal and once the halfway
point of the journey comes around luffy
has the chance to achieve what he set
out to do however he wasn't strong
enough to fight against croc forcing him
to leave and increase his capacity for a
second and a third shot upon which he
succeeds but it doesn't have to be quite
as emphatic as that for a midpoint
reversal to be effective it could quite
simply be something as passive as what
happens in the saiyan saga in the case
of that the working plan for the
majority of the first half was for goku
to receive the training he needs to
overcome vegeta and napa on king kai's
planet he accepts the call to action and
begins to run on snakeway the first of
many challenges he will eventually have
to overcome on his journey to become
powerful enough to defend what he needs
to defend during which all the
supporting cast and subplots revolve
around this particular event with the
plan and therefore our expectations
being goku will finish his training in
time to be there to begin the fight with
the saiyans but that's when the midpoint
reversal occurs goku has finished his
training but not with enough time to
coincide his arrival with that of vegeta
and napas this by cause and effect
injects tension by placing significantly
more stress and pressure on the
supporting cast to survive this fearsome
encounter from another world and these
are all just examples i've chosen but in
reality this can be seen in almost any
story whether it be a book tv program or
feature film as long as it adheres to
one of the most popular and flexible
narrative structures being used today
odds are you'll have a midpoint reversal
seriously keep it in mind the next time
you watch a movie it's almost always
there and why wouldn't it be plans going
awry tension rising and regrouping are
all terrific means of keeping an
audience engaged in whatever you're
writing to help guide the plot and set
up for the big finish in the climax all
the while pushing the hero character
back down again for him to have to lift
himself back up sometimes farther than
he ever has to have done so in the past
like luffy during alabasta and that's
exactly what happens almost beat for
beat in the soul society arc which is
why i think this arc's pacing is
extremely strong in the manga kubo
guides us and the characters involved
through this story allowing us to
believe that we have an idea of what's
happening we have a goal and we have a
plan to achieve it they then act on that
plan and then about halfway through
something happens which changes
everything
watching ichigo genuinely get some
blocks in was one of the most cathartic
things this manga delivered to me
successfully thus far that little smirk
right in the face of yakuya was a
genuinely brilliant moment the likes of
which capitalize on the tension and the
scene perfectly alleviating our feelings
for a moment before dunking on them
moments later
later breeders
oh yeah
mr cat is actually miss cat and you guys
must have loved that in the comments of
my last video when i was calling it mr
cat her entrance into the scene
literally cuts through the tension like
few things this story has achieved and
hand to god this sudden shift in
direction the story has taken i
absolutely love watching ichigo
lifelessly carried off by her as she
manages to make byakuya look like a fool
was thrilling all the while establishing
a new expectation for the audience
immediately which is important for the
entire soul society the tale has
effectively led to this moment only for
each goat to be carried off lifelessly
naturally this removes the goal or at
least adds an air of uncertainty around
it because of this i think kubo decides
to put another time limit on it in other
words three days of training and i
thought that was a high value move
adding a lot more to the story than it
otherwise stands to gain in surprise and
uncertainty without an idea of what
happens next it's difficult for the
audience to fully appreciate what to
expect and by association get excited
for it's one of the many reasons i think
game of thrones final season killed the
ending jon snow's story had been
entirely about him dealing with the
night king and the oncoming winter with
white walkers only his story surrounding
that came to nothing his birth meant
nothing and ultimately he sort of
floundered around until the end
muttering to himself about his aversion
to crowns however before that horrible
ending came halfway through he lost an
obvious goal that differentiated him
from others and thus just sort of was
there thankfully kubo didn't do this
here establishing exact parameters for
which ichigo is to aim helps focus us
and also offers him a chance to involve
other more established characters to
shake things up in byakuya now awaiting
a rematch in three days something i do
want to show my appreciation for that i
otherwise didn't in the first half is
the sheer variety of personalities
littered throughout this arc
each and every captain seems to have a
different demeanor set of values and
overall vibe reflected by their
respective design philosophies which
were fantastic biakuya is very
regimented and cold with his robes hair
and clinical appearance reflecting that
aizen seems introspective warm and
attentive to those around him with his
softer looking hair and character
reflecting that reality by showing
appreciation and concern for his company
unlike others we've been introduced to
some are ruthless others seem laid back
but all are interesting and offer a life
to this place it otherwise wouldn't have
without it
okay now it's at this point in the story
that things start to feverishly rush to
the climax with all the various pieces
once in different complex scenarios
reaching similar conclusions resulting
in a much more tidy setting for our hero
the bleach himself to come and save the
day later after his training of course
now before we touch on that last week i
glanced over it but today i'd like to
talk about it in more detail the side
characters and their exploits while
ichigo is busy being
let's kick things off with chad as we
know chad along with the others were all
split up to varying degrees during the
initial arrival beyond the walls for the
most part urdu and orihime have managed
to avoid conflict but chad wasn't so
lucky well okay to an extent he does run
into the third seat of eighth company
someone called in joji or should i say
in joji runs into his fist
[Music]
then chad is confronted by a particular
captain called kyoraku of eighth company
presented amidst a sea of cherry
blossoms seeing this i won't lie i began
to worry for chad's future in the series
this was before we had ever had any
confrontation with the captain directly
before i mean this was before the
kenpachi fight with ichigo and cherry
blossoms typically symbolize a host of
different things across the world from
love to brilliance to new beginnings
however in japan it can also symbolize
the transience and fragility of life
stunningly beautiful and a dominant
feature of their area during bloom all
good things eventually come to an end
acting as a timeless metaphor for human
existence powerful and glorious when in
season but tragically short-lived
visually acting as a reminder that our
lives too are fleeting and this captain
dude is surrounded by them i'm not sure
if it's an aesthetic but at the time i
genuinely feared for chad going forward
here i genuinely thought that it could
act as a visual indicator that chad
might be dying here alternatively it
could also have been alluding to the
short-lived amount of time ruki has
spent with the group having arrived in
ichigo's life at the same time as when
the cherry blossom bloomed in japan this
could also indicate the great impact she
had on the group despite the short time
she spent there having created in effect
a new beginning for herself on earth or
perhaps i'm reading way too much into it
and kubo just thought hey this look cool
either or whatever
this is my second time partnering up
with opera gx and i once again couldn't
be happier to be talking about a product
i actually use on a daily basis the last
time we checked in i spoke about its
fantastic ability to monitor what
resources the browser is using as well
as being able to limit just how much
power it can take from your system if
you're ever gaming or editing and trying
to browse at the same time i'm sure you
can appreciate just how great this
feature is you may also remember me
talking about its awesome pop-out
feature that's invaluable for
multitasking i'm often pulling up
episodes to refresh my memory when
writing scripts for these videos so
being able to float an adjustable video
frame with just a click over my work is
so unbelievably helpful what's great is
that unlike most browsers opera gx is
fully customizable and supported to the
extent that they even have their own
dedicated platform for it with just a
few clicks you can have your own awesome
animated wallpaper right in your browser
and it's largely all contributed by the
gx community so a huge shout out to them
for making these and if you're into this
sort of stuff i definitely encourage you
to try your hand at making some to
submit download the browser now and see
what you think opera gx is always
evolving though and one of the cool new
features is the ability to keep track of
your social media directly from your
sidebar with just one click you can pull
up your twitter or discord while
browsing anywhere and check in on what's
going on no more navigating to a new tab
it's all there at the touch of a button
heck if you connect spotify to it it'll
automatically pause for you if you feel
like watching a video in a tap and then
resume when you're done for those of you
that like to stay on top of things
you'll also love gxcorner it's a
one-click stop for notifications on free
games deals and most importantly
breaking news for those of you who love
video games and anime this thing really
is an impressive all-in-one beast of a
browser so if you're looking to make a
switch simply click the link down below
in the description and download opera gx
today
the fight however is much like the
others in the ark quite short-lived with
its purpose being to show us another
taste of the captains in action how all
of them seem to be totally different
from each other some interesting
backstory for chad and of course his
resolve
additionally as i mentioned this fight
also takes place before the
confrontation with biakuya and ichigo
which honestly is part of what makes
that confrontation so intense yakuya as
a result is painted as the best of the
best and if this is what happened to
chad when he faced off against this guy
a captain certainly but perhaps not the
strongest of them then how would ichigo
fare
sneaking into the ranks of the soul
society was honestly really fun and a
nice change of pace it's less fighting
and more avoidance of that very conflict
it also creates some really nice
interpersonal intense moments as they at
least try to employ some subtlety and
attempt to bluff their way through the
ranks while avoiding the pursuit of a
captain that knows who they are this
captain in pursuit of them is called
kurotsuchi and to put it bluntly i was
stunned at how on the nose he was
depicted as a heartless psychopath
willing to throw the lies of his
subordinates away as bait detonating and
murdering them all in an effort to seize
or kill orihime and urdu it's obvious
life is meaningless to this guy willing
to as we later find out operate on and
augment his live test subjects torturing
them and reveling in their suffering i
don't want to assume he was inspired by
some less than savory events that took
place during world war ii in nazi
germany but it sort of seems that way
and now that he's cornered urdu we get a
really good fight here
[Music]
this might be the most twisted and
disturbing individual we've had one of
our heroes fight against and the fight
makes urdu look like an absolute badass
but outside of the obvious awesome
visuals i've come to expect from kubo at
this point i think there's a lot to love
about this fight specifically after an
impactful and triumphant opening against
this dude uryu gets caught up in a move
of his that leads to his own paralysis
once again opening urdu up to impressing
him more by overcoming that now i love
kurotsuchi's design it's intentionally
clinical cold and psychotic looking kind
of like a creepy doll come to life
however his dialogue sort of embellishes
this physical trait also admitting
proudly to having tortured and
experimented on the quincy people this
naturally is enough to offer early the
resolve to deal with this but i also
enjoyed how it led to another flashback
for the character himself similar to
chad's we see the impetus for urdu's
knowledge some complexities concerning
his past with his father and most
importantly the essence of a technique
that ends up being his salvation i might
have touched on this once or twice
broadly speaking in my previous videos
but the way this manga is paced has an
effect on the battles i only recently
noticed the fight in question is
honestly quite good teaches us as i said
a bit about uru shows us how virtuous he
can be how powerful he truly is in some
of his past not to mention describes to
us the sort of captain this dastardly
person is however despite the battle
feeling like it covered a decent amount
the fight itself is remarkably sparse
and short and has honestly little to it
basically packing a strong punch into a
proportionately small run time each
chapter because of how focused kubo
seems to be on not cramming tons of
story in seems to cover one major plot
beat per issue one chapter could deal
with exploring who the bad guy is and
another on overcoming a particular
attack and with this focus on
step-by-step narrative progression
systematically overcoming an opponent
like this has the knock-on effect of
attacks that eventually meet their mark
feeling significant and pivotal while
also keeping things short and simple in
other words all killer no filler so to
speak it's worth noting however that
there are other effective means of
structuring and presenting a battle in a
manga it just depends on the sort of
themes and style you're going for really
personally i like what bleach is doing
here but there are tons of others like
one piece during onogoshima which saw a
ton of fighting that while every action
might not be pushing or driving the
story still aided oda's desire to
establish a chaotic and frantic setting
however even outside of the more frantic
team-up battles one-on-one contests in
one piece due to the amount of
exposition necessary tend to have a lot
more back and forth crammed into a
single chapter which again isn't a bad
thing just a difference in approach i
noticed concerning this fight with urdu
however i think it is his best outing
yet it demonstrated a bankai being used
something we'll be exploring a lot more
in the second half ultimately raising
urdu in my estimation and placing him in
a victorious albeit compromising spot
following the contest and so following
both of these fights chad and uryu's
they find themselves in captivity i
wonder if at this point chad felt bad
because he is the only one of the main
group to both get captured and not take
down a captain hmm
while he goes training does take up a
small amount of time in the story it
doesn't really get the focus i thought
that it would now with that said there
is story for ichigo and his training
where he achieves a chance to unlock his
blade's second phase bon kai
which allows him to be many times
stronger than he already was and
honestly it's kind of cool it's achieved
by fighting zengetsu who on some level
represents ichigo mastering his weapon
so to speak it's a nice metaphor however
more attention during this time is
dedicated to other characters that
surround rookie's dire situation and of
course the aizen murder and honestly i
thought this was really important we get
to see the hidden details of the letter
izan left behind and learned that the
blade used for execution the execution
for rukia might be something someone
would be after something massively
powerful and thus presupposes that
ruki's execution has been orchestrated
to create an opportunity to steal it of
all the things i was reading in this
manga whether it be the direction of
rukia's fade ichigo's character and the
supporting cast it was this mystery
surrounding the execution as well as
eisen's murder that i honestly just
couldn't wrap my head around there were
so many variables to consider so many
different pieces of information pointing
me into recording that seem misleading
or curious like for a few pages toshiro
becomes the prime suspect until we see
his inner monologue moments later and
learn as readers that he is in fact
innocent like what's going on and now
renji is training with ichigo i mean
kiss already okay jokes aside upon
reading through this section sharing
time with rukia as she sits in prison
just contemplating her fate it really
made me reflect on the first arc
substitute shinigami and its importance
without it i honestly wouldn't have a
strong enough connection with rukia to
make this arc work at all and thank god
that bond is strong enough between
myself and her because now i get to
befriend new cute characters like
kenpachi as he acts as a pack mule for
the supporting cast that appeared to
have nothing left to do with that said
however i think it is cool that
characters like kenpachi ikaku and
another part of the company whose name i
completely forget stay behind to hold
off the people involved with the
execution i think it's a nice touch
having the people each go defeated and
ultimately changed act as the barrier
between rukia and her impending demise
sort of like the time he spent there
struggling against these foes actually
meant something and wasn't wasted after
all
[Music]
alright so this is a minor complaint but
one aspect i've shown that's very common
that is in all of the big three and is
something i honestly don't know how i
feel about has to do with conveyance and
what that conveyance is meant to do for
the reader in an action film if someone
gets impaled then we know they are done
if someone gets shot then we know that
they are done well most of the time
anyway but in a shown in battle series
what differentiates whether or not
someone is going to die versus someone
who isn't going to die isn't very clear
all the time in fact if you remove the
dialogue entirely where they tell us how
they're feeling it's actually quite
difficult to know take this fight with
kimpachi for example he gets impaled
several times over and he's barely
affected in fact it doesn't seem like
he's affected at all and so it makes me
wonder at what point does damage become
an insufficient metric for us to
understand the flow of the fight in
every other medium where fighting is a
driving force of a narrative the strikes
that land typically serve a purpose a
purpose that indicates that the battle
is either being won or lost and when
death blows are treated as nothing more
than a scratch how exactly are the
actual final blows in these fights
visually meant to have any impact if
they look like they are framed no
differently than the others that
supposedly have no effect and i want to
stress that this isn't a problem unique
to bleach by the way i just kind of
wanted to talk about it naruto and
dragon ball have this issue too heck i'm
sure at a number of points in one piece
characters literally get shot in the
head or have their skulls literally
shattered to pieces only to shake it off
moments later i mean if usopp can have
his skull literally shattered to pieces
in alabasta and walk it off then i don't
know why ace can't survive this
the answer honestly is thematically it
needed to happen
personally i think i'd sacrifice meeting
this visual spectacle for cohesive
narrative and visual consistency and
honestly i feel like it would make the
fights feel so much more meaningful as a
result but i don't know that's just me
[Music]
rinji is determined to save rukia and
i'm all here for it but gets stopped on
his way to save her by biakuya brilliant
everyone's favorite person i love the
civil war type vibes of the soul society
by the way it's really working for me
having spoken about the significance of
cherry blossoms earlier i think it's
also fitting how cherry blossoms are a
theme with one of byakuya's finishing
maneuvers and speaking of which during
this interaction or clash between
byakuya and renji i was reminded time
and again how ridiculously condescending
he really is solidifying my hatred forum
and my admiration and awe over rengi's
bangkai which was really cool and to
tell you the truth rengi's really
started to grow on me over the last few
dozen chapters as a character anyway i
liked him pretty much from the outset
because of his awesome design but it's
his inner conflict loyalty and resolve
that honestly wins me over most of the
time as a reader also did i mention his
bankai looks really cool it's like this
bone snake thing it's awesome and i
really like how it sort of looks like
his blade too the way it kind of extends
and is kind of like i don't know
articulated in a way but i think more
than anything regarding this particular
fight what i really liked was the way
that he wins the battle by getting
biakia down to one knee now i say he
wins the battle but this is a war not a
battle
[Music]
this dude is scary elitist and i have
absolutely no idea what he ultimately
wants either now that i think of it does
he want the execution blade if so why
the battle ends with him making a fool
of renji making him feel like dirt
however once again much like how
kompatchy and ikaku have been moved to
action ichigo is at the back of their
minds in renji's case he acts as
inspiration a source of resolve to
remind him of what's important of what's
possible as a result it creates one of
the best fights in the series it's
awesome and the poetry of biakia's
arrogance contrasted perfectly against
renji's tenacious boasts culminating
ultimately in the fight being won by
biakiya but only after being proven
wrong by renji not once but twice the
fangs of the simple beast that he was
referred to as could in fact reach the
magnificent moon that is
and all of this is taking place during
ichigo's training i mean it really plays
second fiddle to this and honestly
rightfully so kimpatch's fight with the
two other captains was way more fun to
watch than i thought it would be he
seems to be a simple character thus far
but to be honest that helps make the
fights easy to read through they're
straightforward bursts of fun and
passion for this guy and watching him
use his monstrous instincts to overcome
these hurdles that present themselves
like the blind situation is just as
cathartic as you would expect
particularly now that he's on ichigo's
side
interestingly despite this being the
moment we've been building to for the
bulk of a volume and a half once biakia
and ichigo exchange words the fight
we've been waiting for just gets put on
pause in favor of checking in with a
series of other fights like that which
concerns miss cat and a couple of other
more chill captains duking it out with
their superior and i think i know why
when i first started reading the soul
society arc i did so with the knowledge
that many consider it to be the best arc
of the series others refute this claim
however but the bulk seemed to agree
with the sentiment so why i wondered
this to myself and now obviously i'm
writing this not having finished reading
the arc itself and there is of course
room for me to be wrong but one of the
strengths that made this arc as terrific
as i think it largely turned out to be
was the groundwork that was set by the
substitute chunigami arc significantly
more episodic in nature than soul
society all the setup for this
fan-favored second arc of the series was
done long before it ever appeared on the
pages before you or on the screens in
front of your eyes everything from the
gold to the systems that govern how this
world works not to mention the
motivating factors all of it was there
and it's that which i feared this arc
might be missing however potentially it
might also be trying to do that here
with these fights that are taking time
away from the main event in order for
this story to progress beyond soul
society in a satisfying fashion this
very arc needs to set up plot elements
to catapult us onward towards the next
story seamlessly without that it runs
the risk of killing the momentum and as
of right now there seems to be only a
single goal and once that goal is
accomplished it's sort of back to the
drawing board the saiyan saga for
example seamlessly segues into the
frieza saga in z but in super the goku
black act abruptly ends and then the
universe survival arc starts in its own
new story the fights that are taking
place right now are interesting however
but they feel like i should care about
them a lot more than i otherwise do
particularly the leader of the soul
society that old man versus his two
pupils i don't know any of these
characters well enough to get as much
from this outing that i otherwise feel
like i should be so my hope is that
these fights result in a continuation to
the story rather than existing purely
for spectacle because if it is for
spectacle i feel like it's being lost on
me oh also because the spectacle feeling
isn't really there some of the time
either despite mrs cat's opening gambit
against shaolin there's a flashback that
kicks things off with a page crammed
full of exposition and i'm gonna call it
out because it's really an anomaly thus
far in this series which has been as
i've said panels brilliantly so i'm
gonna give this one a pass but that page
wow that that's not a good page
after all of that we do eventually get
back to the ichigo fight where we learn
that the blade's power is called piercer
of the heavens and i honestly love that
name for ichigo perhaps a poetic
callback to something biaki equipped at
renji when they fought citing himself
like the moon unable to be reached by
mere mortal beasts this blade offers
ichigo that very mechanism with which he
can reach byakuya with it he can pierce
the heavens the heavens being in this
case biakia's stupid face and to tell
you the truth this fight is awesome made
possible because biakia has effectively
been depicted as this god amongst
captains in the soul society composed
arrogant cold talented and immeasurably
powerful the most we'd ever gotten out
of him up until now was a bending of the
knee due to some uneven footing but in
this fight we get to see something else
ichigo's bankai
this is a level of vulnerability i've
never seen byakia have to endure and it
only gets better there's a really nice
chapter entitled the one who changed the
world with the message and implication
being that rookie's presence in ichigo's
life changed him as a person for the
better however i do also like that it
ends with ichigo's friends who've been
absent from this climax for the most
part getting to see how great each go
has in fact become however i think it's
also trying to convey that much like
rukia each go has changed or he may and
all of his allies now also as the fight
rages on ichigo goes on the back foot
he's slowing down running out of energy
he's going to lose he begs pleads with
his body to move he says out loud that
he wants to win and then
i [ __ ]
knew it as soon as i read the cayenne
flashback with rukia i knew that
something similar would happen to ichigo
here that flashback earlier we get with
cayenne and rukia i feel will be
exploring contrast with later on with
each or maybe it won't i don't know but
you gotta admit cayenne seems to look an
awful lot like ichigo it also explains
why rukia is so steadfast in wanting to
protect ichigo's life at all costs but i
also knew as soon as cayenne went
berserker mode that something like that
might also be possible for someone like
ichigo and seeing as that seems to be
the case i've been predicting that this
would happen since the beginning of the
soul society or more specifically ever
since i saw him first transform with the
mask on but i don't think that's the
interesting part of this narrative
decision at least not entirely it feels
like right now while this is a part of
ichigo that he is literally fighting
against physically and thematically i
think that very lack of acceptance is
what's holding him back actually we've
seen him acknowledge the utility of this
monstrous form and now we're seeing how
effective he can be once again but one
thing they both share in common is a
lack of respect and synergy with each
other the idea and mistake i think being
committed by ichigo here potentially is
that he thinks this isn't him when in
reality they are one of the same
partners as it were to borrow a phrase
from their previous meeting my initial
impression right now is as it was last
week it feels like the message is that
we all have a monster inside of us one
that is capable of doing tremendous harm
and damage if left unchecked and in
response to this reality many might try
to either hide or indulge in this form
however both are bad choices the idea
being that if you totally reject this
side of you you run the risk of becoming
a useless doormat unable to stand up for
yourself or your loved ones and on the
other hand if you are overly indulgent
in this monstrous side of you you become
just that a monster so in reality i
think the story being told here quite
brilliantly might i add is that of
learning to respect and control the
monster inside of you accepting that
it's a part of you and using it to your
benefits so that you become neither a
monster or a doormat but instead a
powerful and caring person this is
something i honestly thought naruto
tackled rather well with kurama taking
advantage of him when he was weak
similarly this is happening with ichigo
however i think bleach could tell this
particular narrative in a much more
compelling and effective way simply
because this creature living in ichigo
isn't some fox spirit but instead is
very much him and of all the fights in
this arc this one felt the most massive
in scope at least so far however
following this event things get weird
we've all but achieved the goal so all
we would think that needs to be done is
leave right well
not so much we end up spending a
considerable amount of time with other
characters as they stumble across a room
full of dead bodies
but that's not even the weirdest part
[Music]
this
legitimately knocked me for a loop i
mean this is a great way of skewing the
audience's point of view because i was
using eisens left behind information as
gospel for me to base all of my
assumptions on as i'm sure kubo wanted
me to but now with this sudden
realization
i'm like okay so all of it was a lie
which means once again i don't know
anything and once again i don't know
what the implications are of this i was
definitely misled by his kind outward
demeanor but other than that i had no
idea someone like that could conceivably
fake his death with high-ranked members
of the soul society surrounding him so
in a way while i don't get the aha
moment like i wanted to get it is an
interesting ruffle to the story that
makes me ask more questions which is
good considering this isn't the last arc
of the series and kubo does want us to
keep reading the ending to this arc is
utter chaos with so many different plot
threads being paid off taking twists i
didn't expect along with revealing new
information considering the world i
never knew and yet strangely enough it
ends rather conclusively however not
entirely so eisen is the driving force
of this ark's conclusion and he is every
bit deserving of that position
immeasurably powerful cunning in all the
most underhanded of ways disappearing
from before toshiro only to find himself
before renji carrying rukia and even
moments like this where we see someone
like rinji struggling to defend and
survive against eisen helps to bring
attention to the real strengths of this
arc how the newly introduced characters
have progressed far beyond what they
were first introduced as someone like
renji nothing but a dog for the soul
society now fights for something he
believes in against insurmountable odds
despite the rules and eisen someone who
i genuinely thought was a chill guy ends
up being the big bad on the entire arc
and by the looks of it multiple arcs
with the struggle itself against eisen
coming out as brilliant specifically
because it gives ichigo the opportunity
to say this
come on that's a great line there is a
period of monologuing eisen enjoys a
little too much right after he puts down
ichigo that felt a little too expository
but honestly that's just a taste thing
villains have been doing this for
centuries and the fact this character is
rooted in his own arrogance lends this
scene a believable quality that i think
it needed he explains the reasoning
behind why he's doing what he's doing
and alludes to something called
hollification the process of exceeding
your potential i think by means we've
seen through the likes of ichigo and
cayenne and following that he takes out
the whole gyoku out of rukia and jin
goes to kill her but
oh my god the [ __ ] did something
right he did the right thing
i retract what i said about hating him
and also he's your brother-in-law and
was married to your now dancing what's
happening this can and sheldon show up
to restrain eisen which was badass and
despite other forces that complicate the
matter showing up to fight against the
sight of good the giant at the gate from
the beginning as well as the souls from
the slums rushed to their aid all the
folks who ichigo helped along the way
have come to their rescue to make a
difference giving this arc a wonderful
sense of completeness and closure
however one thing i will say about this
ending that i didn't like in retrospect
was the lack of involvement of the main
crew after all the training they did it
didn't really amount to much of anything
substantial in the story beyond a couple
of interesting fights and some comedic
scenarios for otohime unless i'm
forgetting something their involvement
didn't feel all that important in the
end what could have been a cool idea i
thought would have been to hint at
urdu's powers still somewhat being there
and then when the time came for ichigo
to be motionless or crippled on the
ground in front of aizen for uru to
puppeteer him to get either him or rukia
to safety i thought that would have been
a really cute idea and i don't know
orihime could have healed ichigo off to
the side away from eisen something it's
a dumb idea but it's honestly stemming
from me wanting the og gang to do more
than they ultimately ended up doing in
this arc and i think that's unfortunate
and also kind of reasonable but overall
i thought this arc was really fun and
pretty solid it does the traditions
shown in arc structure justice in many
respects and is filled with all the
trappings bells and whistles that you'd
expect from the genre at this time in
all the best ways but one thing that did
surprise me was
how i felt about the arc and this series
after finishing this story especially
considering i'm such a big story and
narrative guy the ending of this arc
really hit the spot for me and maybe not
for the reasons you or i might have
expected when it was just the guys
healing out in the afterglow of the
battle when it was just orihime and
ichigo running around like goofballs
with renji and byakuya it was just fun
and sort of made me miss the first arc
that little bit more because it had more
time for those more understated less
consequential moments and character-rich
dialogue ruki again to apologize and
ultimately choosing to stay in the soul
society was an interesting idea but
ichigo immediately respecting that
decision was the icing on the cake that
this arc really needed for me i mean i
just love these characters they are by
far and away the story's strongest
quality and this is coming from someone
who loves the arabic in this manga to an
unhealthy degree i don't know where the
story will go from here obviously but
considering eisen pieced out through a
giant menos grande mash pit in the sky
i'm guessing the options are limitless
next week i take my first step into
potentially controversial territory and
i'm honestly very hopeful but until then
i've been totally not mark i'll see you
all next week and thank you all so much
for taking the time to watch this video
[Music]
you